thousands of unemployment claimants
could see a positive benefits being
deposited into their accounts
because lawmakers went down to the wire
to get that stimulus bill to the
president's desk
our joe mohler is live to explain joe
well now that bill was signed into law
deiter actually has to wait for
directions from
the department of labor now this part of
the process could take several weeks
and that could cause a delay in payments
it would be for that 300
additional benefit and those 10 weeks of
benefits that would carry us through
march
amber hansen runs the nevada pandemic
unemployment assistance facebook group
as the stimulus bill gets put into
action pua claimants should prepare for
a pause in payments
i know that it probably will take about
two weeks for the dol to give their
guidance to
each individual state and then we'll see
how fast
dieter rises to the occasion monday in a
statement deters said
as was the case with previous federal
unemployment programs deter must receive
guidance from the department of labor
before it can fully implement the
changes
and begin issuing payments they cannot
make needed changes until the dol
gives them direction that means they
can't pay poor claimants
until then there probably will not be
funding for approximately four to eight
weeks i'm guesstimating
hansen is a pool claimant herself she
says this is a concern
she hopes the stimulus checks can come
sooner than later
hopefully direct payments will be a lot
faster this time around
but yes people do need to prepare also
in the stimulus bell was an extra 300
weekly payment for all claimants those
are starting the week ending january 2nd
according to dieter claimants who have
payments paused will still be paid the
missing payments once dieter can begin
them
it's a nationwide crisis there are going
to be americans across the country that
are going to have
at least a month gap before they see
continued benefits and they're going to
have to prepare for that
and i did speak to hanson just a short
time ago once again she is in
communication with someone in the strike
force who says they are preparing their
systems for this they're in the same
boat as
every other state and as far as those
300 payments if you are eligible for
those
you will you will be paid for them
reporting live joe moeller 8 news now
and joe last week was the deadline for
dieter to resume payments for some
claimants who had
their payments stopped so is there any
difference coming with that
yeah well those those claimants you're
talking about are the pool claimants ui
payments stopped and then they were
supposed to have them resumed due to
that court order
i did speak to hanson about that today
because she runs that really popular
facebook page she says she has noticed
more claimants are getting paid or and
their portals are being changed as well
we'll have to see what happens
at the hearing update later this week